Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. You hear that? Paid. And done. That's the sound of bills being paid on time. But with the BMO Eclipse Rise Visa Card, paying your bills could sound like this. Yes!
Earn rewards for paying your bill in full and on time each month. Rise to rewards with the BMO Eclipse Rise Visa Card. Terms and conditions apply. Hey guys, you know what this playground could use? A wine country, huh? A redwood forest would be cool. Ski slopes! Wait! Did we just invent California? Discover why California is the ultimate playground at visitcalifornia.com.
Hello dearest listener. In the thick of the winter season, you may be in need of some joie de vivre. Well, look no further, honey, because Sunwing's Best Value Vacays has your budget-friendly escapes, all the way to five-star luxury. Yes, you heard correctly, budget and luxury, all in one place. So instead of ice scraping and teeth-chattering, choose coconut sipping and pool splashing.
Oh, and, uh, yeah, book by February 16th with your local travel advisor or as... -♪ Sunwing, that's the end! Yeah, book by February 16th with your local travel advisor or as... When I was a little chap, I had a passion for maps. I would look for hours at South America or Africa or Australia and lose myself in all the glories of exploration. At that time, there were many blank spaces on the earth, and when I saw one that looked particularly inviting on a map, I would put my finger on it and say, when I grow up, I will go there. There was one, the biggest, the most blank, so to speak, that I had a hankering after. It had got filled since my boyhood with rivers and lakes and names. It had ceased to be a blank space of delightful mystery, a white patch for a boy to dream
gloriously over. It had become a place of darkness. But there was in it one river especially, a mighty big river, that you could see on the map, resembling an immense snake uncoiled, with its head in the sea, its body at rest, curving afar over a vast country, and its tail lost in the depths of the land. Dash it all, I thought to myself. They can't trade without using some kind of craft on that lot of fresh water. Steamboats.
Why shouldn't I try to take charge of one? I went on along Fleet Street, but could not shake off the idea. The snake had charmed me. So that is Marlow, the hero and the narrator of Joseph Conrad's novella Heart of Darkness, which was first published in Blackwoods magazine in 1899. It famously provided the inspiration for Apocalypse Now about the American experience in Vietnam, but it was originally written about the European colonial experience in Africa, probably the greatest, the most influential, possibly the most controversial book about that ever written about the moral dangers of colonialism and also about the sense of the darkness that
lurks in the heart of the human soul because the darkness in that title, Heart of Darkness, has many different levels. There's also the darkness that is London. So Marlow is talking about this on a boat on the River Thames, narrating it to three friends. So the sense that the darkness in Africa is reflecting the darkness in the heart of the European is kind of at the heart of the idea of the book, isn't it, Dominic? It is indeed, Tom't it, Dominic? It is indeed, Tom. Yeah, absolutely. And we'll get onto Heart of Darkness next week because we'll do an episode about Joseph Conrad and about this book, which is one of the most
influential books, I would argue, of the modern age. And it's a book that I think anticipates so much of the culture of the 20th century and wrestling with kind of man's capacity for evil and the possibilities of violence and brutality that have been opened up by kind of globalization and by history. And so we'll get onto that next week. It's a book rooted in Conrad's own experience. So just to give people a sense, he had visited a specific place at a specific point of time. That place is the Congo Free State under the rule of King Leopold II of Belgium. Conrad had visited it nine years before he wrote the book as a merchant seaman
steering a boat as Marlowe does into the heart of Africa. And we'll talk about his experience as I said next week. But this week we're going to look at the real history that underpins that story. So the story of the Congo Free State, probably the darkest stain in the history of European colonialism, what Conrad himself called, and I quote, the vilest scramble for loot that ever disfigured the history of human conscience. So to give people a sense, we are in Central Africa between 1885 and 1908. It's the country that is now known as the Democratic Republic of the Congo, an enormous country. A country that is as big as Britain, France, Germany, Italy and Spain put together.
Indeed, it's as big as the entire United States east of the Mississippi and is actually largely unknown outside its own borders, isn't it Tom? I guess people have a vague sense of Congo because it became Zaire under president Mobutu, who was kind of the archetype of the kleptocratic African strongman. And yet there's a sense that, that no one was quite as kleptocratic or brutal actually as Leopold the second. And there's a case for saying that he is the model for much that goes wrong with Africa in the wake of independence.
Wouldn't you say? I would, absolutely. I would. I think lots of people would say that this is a kind of foundational moment for the Congo from which nothing ever goes right thereafter. In that 23-year period when King Leopold is in charge of the Congo, there's a fair claim that it's one of the worst places to live that has ever existed. There's a brilliant book on this called King Leopold's Ghost by the American writer Adam Hochschild. We'll be borrowing from that book very liberally. So a big shout out to Adam Hochschild's book at the beginning. Not an uncontroversial book itself. In the next week's bonus episode, we'll talk about some of the arguments about that book. But
anyway, in King Leopold's Ghost, he says this is one of the great mass killings in human history. A death toll, he says, of holocaust dimensions. Exactly how many people die in the Congo Free State is disputed. But it's millions, isn't it? It's millions. It's almost certainly millions. And some estimates would go as high as 10 million. It's not just a story about horror. It's a story about celebrity, about international relations, royalty. There's a lot of sex in it. There's loads of politics. It's a story about modernity as well, because this is a new age.
It's the age of the camera. So there's lots of photography. Photography is really important, newspapers, telegraphs and so on. And actually, as we're getting into in our third episode, it proves the provocation, the cause for one of the great human rights campaigns in all history, arguably the foundational human rights campaign of the great human rights campaigns in all history, arguably the foundational human rights campaign of the 20th century. Yeah, you say of the 20th century, I mean it joins the abolitionist movement of the late 18th and early 19th century, which gets rid of slavery, with the human rights
movements of the late 20th century. And it's interesting that it's very, very anglophone, isn't it? It's very cent centered in Britain and in the United States. And again, Britain's role in all this is really, really intriguing. It's quite, I mean, intriguingly ambivalent really. It is indeed. Yeah. It's, it's such a rich and interesting story. So it definitely merits a series and like all good series, it needs a
riveting central character, in this case, a villain. And history has absolutely provided us with one. And this is King Leopold II of Belgium, who, Hochschild says, is as interesting, as multi-layered, as greedy, as cunning, as charming, and as untrustworthy as any of Shakespeare's villains. And if he is the villain, the great irony is he never, ever sets foot in the Congo. He never lays eyes on the Congo. His villainy, as it were, is carried out from afar, which makes him a very 20th century figure.
You think of all these dictators who kill so many millions of people without ever shedding blood themselves. But also you could say if you were an anti-capitalist that he's kind of the exemplification of great corporations now who leech money from distant parts of the world, rely on products made by slave labor. Leopold is kind of the archetype of that as well, wouldn't you say? He is indeed. He is and we'll absolutely get into that. This is the classic example, you might say, of the rapacity of corporate capitalism carried to its ultimate murderous extreme.
But let's start with Leopold himself. So he was born in 1835 when Belgium had been independent from the Netherlands for five years. So he's the son of the very first king of the Belgians, who's also called Leopold. He's brought up at a castle called Laken, which is outside Brussels, where he spends most of his time. He speaks French and German and English, not interestingly Flemish, which is the language of most of his subjects. Now Leopold's parents, Leopold and Louise, had a pretty miserable loveless marriage and they treated their son very, very coldly. So if he wanted to talk to his father, he had to apply through a secretary for an audience.
And when his father wanted to tell his son something, he got a secretary to do it for him. To be fair, that is how I communicate with Katie and Eliza. So you know what? When I was reading this, the parallels between you and King Leopold were leaping off the page. Unbelievable. So yeah, what is it about me and the 20th century monarchs? The Kaiser, Leopold the second? Yeah, it's chilling. So Leopold, maybe this will ring a bell with you, Tom. He grows up
a moody, kind of gangling and, and humorless boy. That's me. But the thing is, even at the time, his father says of him, he's very cunning. His father compares him to, with a fox says Leopold is like a fox. He slowly and stealthily picks out his path. Storks the chickens. Exactly. And then he makes his move. So by the 1850s, Leopold is in his teens.
He's becoming, I think it's fair to say, an extremely awkward and unattractive young man. People always comment on how unbelievably tall he is. He's a bit like Baron Trump. He's massively tall and awkward looking. But with less knowledge of crypto, presumably. Presumably, yes. He's got an enormous beard and everybody comments on his absolutely enormous nose. So Disraeli said of it, it's such a nose as a young prince has in a fairy tale,
thanks to the intervention of a kind of, of a malignant fairy. So he's not a looker, I think it's fair to say, and he's very, very charmless. So, you know, he has to compensate for that with his cunning. When he's 18 years old, his father takes him to Vienna to get a Habsburg bride. And this is a 16-year-old called Archduchess Marie Henriette and she's great. Yeah, she's like the Emperor Claudius and Carmen Harris, isn't she? She has a tremendous braying laugh. She does. She's got a great laugh. It echoes around Belgium. And she loves laughing. She loves laughing. And Leopold is shocked by this because
he hates laughing. They go to Venice on holiday and he behaves really coldly to her. He won't let it go on a gondola that she's booked and all this. And she bursts into tears and people see this in public. They say, oh dear, this is an ill-starred marriage. And a month after they got married, she tells one of her friends, if God hears my prayers, I shan't go on living much longer. That's not what you want to hear after a honeymoon. So much of Leopold's colonial ambitions, there is an argument that basically it stems from
his own insecurity and misery, that it's a massive kind of displacement exercise. Anyway, he doesn't actually become King of Belgium till 1865. So he spends a lot of time waiting for his father to die. And while he's doing that, he has this kind of gnawing insecurity that he's going to be inheriting a country that is just a sort of pathetic minnow on the world stage. Of course, Belgium is kind of squashed between France and an increasingly unified Germany. And Leopold feels this very keenly. He says of Belgium, petit pays, petit gens, little country, little people. And he thinks, you know, I deserve better than the Belgian people. And what he
really wants is an empire. He wants colonies and he's very aggrieved that he's inheriting a kingdom that doesn't have any. Three years before he becomes king of the Belgians, he goes on holiday to Spain and he goes to Seville and he spends his time in Seville. He spends weeks at the great archive of the Indies going through the records looking at just how much money Spain had made from its colonies. So this is the 16th century isn't it? The conquistadors. The conquistadors, how much money they had made from the territories they exploited. And this fires his imagination. He makes trips to Ceylon and to Burma to see
how the British make money from their colonies. He reads a book called Java or How to Manage a Colony, which is all about the Dutch in the East Indies. And this is written unbelievably. You've seen the bloke who wrote this book? Yeah, very funny. JWB Money. You see, if he ran a bank, I'd very happily advertise his bank on the rest of the system. JWB Money Bank. Invest your money in it. Well, you should advertise his book. Money's book is all about how you get a colony to turn a profit. You see, that's what Leopold is interested in. Even more than the prestige
and certainly a lot more than any possible civilizing mission aspect of colonialism, what he cares about is cash. And in this book, JWB Money says the Dutch have turned a profit from Java by using forced labor to have plantations and all this kind of thing. And Dominic, the fact that it's Dutch colonies, I mean that must really irritate him. Of course, they're great rivals. The great rivals. I mean, even more than the Germans or the French having colonies. The Dutch. Awful. So he looks at the Dutch and he says, they're very unsentimental, they've used forced labour. And it is clear, he writes, the only way to civilise and uplift these indolent and corrupt
peoples is basically by forcing them to work so that we can make money. So here's the great paradox. Other Belgians don't really care about colonies. They are very conscious they're only a small and newly independent country. They don't even really have a merchant navy of their own, so how could they possibly maintain a colonial empire? But for Leopold, all of his misery, all of his loneliness and awkwardness, I think he has poured into this great project of acquiring colonies. He believes this is the only thing that will make him happy. Well, it's interesting, isn't it, that geography apparently was his only subject that he was
interested in as a boy. So it's a little bit like Marlow at the beginning of this episode, this idea of looking at the world and Marlow dreams of going on adventures there and Leopold dreams of basically grabbing bits of it and using it to make money. He absolutely does indeed. He reminds me, reading the book by Adam Hochstrasz, I was reminded of Scrooge. So Scrooge who, you know, deep down what Scrooge wants, Scrooge wants love and he's become a miser and a terrible person. You are a sentimentalist.
Well, no, I don't think you can be sentimental about King Leopold II as we will see. But you're saying that all the horrors of the Congo is because he didn't have love as a child. I think his loveless life and his obsessiveness, he's not just an ordinary colonialist as we will see. There is something really weirdly obsessive about him and I wonder how much of that, I mean also the way he behaves, the stuff with, as we will see, his obsession with hygiene is very, very peculiar. And with very young ladies.
And with very, very young girls, exactly. There's a lot of bad things to be said, I think it's fair to say, about King Leopold II. Anyway, 1865, he becomes king at last. Now for the next 10 years, he doesn't actually manage to get the empire he wants. He investigates various schemes. He'd like to buy a bit of Argentina. He'd like to buy a bit of the Nile Delta. He even talks about acquiring Fiji, but he doesn't really get anywhere. But not Greenland.
They're not Greenland, no. But in 1875, he thinks he might be onto something. He's offered Spain cash for the Philippines for the second time. And to his deep disappointment, they turn him down again. And he says to one of his courtiers, OK, I'm going to have a look at Africa now. Maybe Africa is the place. So now at last in this story, we come to Africa. Now, the great scramble for Africa, which people think of as a 19th century thing,
is actually really only concentrated in the final decades of the 19th century. So at this point, 1875, it hasn't happened. The French are in Algeria, the Portuguese are in what become Mozambique and Angola, the British and the Burj both have footholds in South Africa, and various countries have kind of trading ports and enclaves on the coast of West Africa. But about three quarters of Africa, really meaning the interior, has not yet been penetrated by European empires. For Europeans, the wealth of Africa is associated with the coast. There's the assumption that there's nothing in the middle that would be worth the effort of colonising.
Exactly. People just think, well, it's just impenetrable jungle. What could possibly be there? It's a blank space, as Conrad puts it. But by this point, the mid 1870s, Africa is making the news in a way it hasn't ever done before. There have been a series of very eye-catching expeditions. And of course, the most famous one, which lots of listeners will have heard of, is the expedition by the journalist Henry Morton Stanley to find the missionary David Livingston in modern day Tanzania in 1871, which was financed by the New York Herald. And thanks to these new innovations of cheap newspapers and the Telegraph, Stanley and Livingston
become international celebrities far beyond Britain and America. So they're making front page news in Belgium and King Leopold, we know, follows the story very closely and actually kept a sort of scrapbook, including handwritten notes that he was making following Stanley's journey. And it's interesting because Livingston is all about fighting slavery. His heart is in the right place. Stanley, a much more ambivalent figure. I mean, he's looking for Livingston basically to make a name for himself.
Exactly. For celebrity and for money are two things which will play a big part in the story. So the question for Leopold is, can he get them? He wants a colony that will turn a profit. Can you make money from Africa? And the answer is yes. Not through slavery, as you once could, but through something that is extremely fashionable and very lucrative, and that something is ivory. Now the Victorians are obsessed by ivory. It's exotic because of course it comes from elephant tusks, but it's also unbelievably useful and malleable because it's really, really easy to carve ivory.
So if you went into a sort of genteel Victorian household anywhere in the Western world in the Western world in the 1870s or 1880s, there would be the handles of cutlery, there would be billiard balls, there would be combs, fans, there would be brooches, there would be chess pieces, piano keys, false teeth. All of these kinds of things are made of ivory. Because Hochstrasse compares it actually to plastic, doesn't he? It's such a kind of useful product, which is brilliant for the Victorians and obviously very bad news for the elephants.
Exactly, exactly. And you can make so much money from it. So two elephant tusks will give you hundreds of piano keys or thousands upon thousands of false teeth. And it sounds comical, but there's an awful lot of money to be made here. And Stanley, after returning from his expedition, has gone round telling people, my God, there is so much ivory in equatorial Africa, that the people there use it for their doorposts because it's just so plentiful.
So it's kind of ivory equivalent of El Dorado. Exactly. That sense of that this is portable wealth. Exactly it is. Which is the key to gold in the New World, wasn't it? Exactly. In the 16th century. But the difference between the 16th century and now is that to acquire a colony, I think
you have to try much harder to present it as part of a civilising mission. So this is the high point, this is of high Victorianism, the belief in kind of moral uplift and Europe's right to the moral leadership of the planet and all these things that we may well think of now as being freighted with hypocrisy or of patronizing condescension. But at the time, people do actually take genuinely seriously. So Leopold knows that he will have to, I think, tick three boxes if he wants a colony. First of all, he has to present it as a scientific project, an intellectual project.
So literally filling in those blank spaces, mapping what has previously been unknown. Secondly, I think he has to tick the moral uplift box. So he has to say, well, I only want a colony because I want to spread the gospel of Christianity. Of course, something that matters tremendously to the Victorians. But also Dominic, the spreading of Christianity is also intimately associated with the campaign to abolish slavery. Yes, that's the third thing. Britain has been leading that campaign since the early 19th century, and it has provided
an absolutely crucial kind of moral justification for what has been a process of expansion of British imperial control. So Livingston, even though he's not overtly an imperialist, the fact that he is carving out a moral mission for Britain in the middle of Africa is obviously very useful from an imperial point of view. And I guess that Leopold is, I mean, he reads the Times, doesn't he, every morning? He is very alert to the kind of symbiosis between that moral mission to eradicate slavery and imperialism in the British form. And he wants a bit of it.
I think you're absolutely right. I think he absolutely sees what's going on with the other empires. I think in Leopold's case, what makes him slightly unusual is that all the evidence we have of his letters and so on is that for him, the profit motive is all and that the rest of it is effectively just a justification for making money. I mean, he's pretty shameless about that, I would say. So this is how he proceeds. And I have to say he's a terrible man, King Leopold, but he really is a cunning and a methodical and a clever man.
A full-pine figure. He is. So his first step is to convene a big geographical conference in Brussels at the end of 1876. And he invites all the big celebrities of the sort of the Africa industry of the day. So there are explorers from France and Germany. He's got a celebrity explorer called Gerhold Rolfs, who had actually had himself circumcised so that he could pass for a Muslim in the Sahara. So, you know, somebody who had suffered for his quest, his
exploration. He's got the president of the British Anti-Slavery Society, Sir Thomas Foul Buxton. He's got the president of the Church Missionary Society, Sir John Kenway. He's even got the bloke who used to command the Royal Navy's Indian Ocean Anti-Slavery Squadron. So he is ticking all of those boxes. He's inviting a lot of people who are genuinely animated by what we might call humanitarian, as well as imperialistic concerns. And he welcomes them and he says, you know, I dream of a crusade worthy of the century of progress to open to civilization, the only part of our globe, which has not yet penetrated to pierce the darkness, which hangs over entire peoples, that word darkness again, which is going to come up
throughout this series. And he says to them, don't think that I want anything for myself. He says, I have a very idea of it. I have no, I'm talking no ambition other than to serve Belgium. Now that's as we've seen as a lie. He despises Belgium. And he, as we will also see, he doesn't want to serve Belgium at all. He only wants to serve himself. And he says to them, look, I've assembled you because I think it'd be nice for us to identify places in the blank spaces of Africa, which could be bases, which could be kind of, they could be for host, they could be hospitals, they could be scientific research centers, they could be trading stations. With an emphasis on the trading.
Yes, exactly. I love it. And these will be run. I don't want to, I mean, Belgium won't run them, because we don't want to. stations with an emphasis on the trading. And these will be run. I don't want to, I mean, Belgium won't run them because we don't want to. We have to see the last thing we'd want to the colony. He says, we'll set up an international African association and based on one of basic in Brussels actually. And for its first chairman, I mean, if no one else wants to do it, I'd, I'd very happy.
Yeah. first chairman, I mean, if no one else wants to do it, I'd very happily put myself forward. And everybody, you know, they all fall for this. Oh, what a lovely idea. What a kind man. I mean, we're recording this today after the Trump inauguration, where all these heads of tech companies that until Trump won the election were all over their mission being to spread happiness and joy and promote diversity and equity. And now they've been all that very nakedly. Do you think that this is the first example of kind of avaricious corporations dressing up their
greed behind a kind of show of piety and... It's got to be one of the first, doesn't it? One of the early ones, one of the most eye-catching early ones, definitely. Because it is a brilliant manoeuvre. Of course it is. If you have global ambitions. And all these people believe it. They completely believe it.
And here's the thing, the International African Association, which sounds like it's a charity and which they have all endorsed, is actually a private company run by Leopold himself for his benefit. For his benefit. So the only thing he doesn't have actually is the colony. You know, he's got the association, but he doesn't have the colony. And where is he going to get the colony? Well, the answer is from the one person who wasn't there at that meeting in Brussels. And this is the most famous of all African explorers.
We've already mentioned him, Henry Morton Stanley. Now we'll just sketch Stanley very briefly, because he really is worthy of a Restless History series in himself. He had an amazing life, Stanley. He was born in Wales in 1841, and he was born as John Rawlins Bastard. He was the illegitimate son of a housemaid. That's the entry that is in the Book of Births. He spends his childhood in a workhouse. He emigrates to New Orleans when he's 18 years old. He fought for the Confederates, then he fought for the Union, then he joined the Union Navy. Then he renamed himself Henry Morton Stanley after a New Orleans businessman. And then he became a journalist. He went to the Ottoman Empire, he went to Persia, he went to the Crimea, he went to Abyssinia with the British expedition.
But most famously, the New York Herald sent him to Central Africa to find Dr. Livingston, which he did, near Lake Tanganyika in 1871. And then he invented, almost certainly invented, this fantastic line. So disappointing. I know it's disappointing. Let's pretend that he said it. Dr Livingston, I presume, when he met Livingston, which flashed around the world and made him a household name, a genuine international celebrity. And he writes it up in enormously long books, doesn't he? Yes, he does, which have great sellers.
So he gets commissioned to write one book and he ends up writing three. That's very, nothing wrong with that, Tom. I commend that kind of behavior. Very familiar. So then he went on another expedition three years later, sent this time by the New York Herald and the Daily Telegraph in London to map the Great Lakes and to look for the source of the Nile. And that's where he's been during Leopold's conference. And he has begun that, hasn't he, on the east coast of Africa at Zanzibar. Yeah. And he's heading westwards and he wouldn't be the first European to have gone from East to West coast, but he is the first who does it basically by following the line of the Congo. Exactly. An incredibly well publicised journey, one that was followed by newspaper readers across the world, as you would follow reports of great sporting fixtures or something. Tremendous excitement. In August 1877, Stanley reached
所以他受托写一本书，最后却写了三本。这很好，没什么不对的，汤姆。我赞赏这种行为。非常熟悉。三年后，他开始了另一次探险，这次是由《纽约先驱报》和伦敦《每日电讯报》派遣，旨在绘制五大湖地图并寻找尼罗河的源头。这就是他在利奥波德会议期间的去向。他已经开始了，不是吗，在非洲东海岸的桑给巴尔。是的。他正向西前进，他不会是第一个从东海岸走到西海岸的欧洲人，但他却是第一个基本上沿着刚果河一线完成这一壮举的人。没错。这是一次宣传得极好的旅程，就像关注重大体育赛事或其他活动的报道一样，世界各地的报纸读者都在关注着它。无比兴奋。1877年8月，斯坦利抵达了
the trading post of Boma, which is on the right bank of the Congo River near the coast. An extraordinary, extraordinary achievement. 7,000 miles Tom in three years he did on foot. Now Leopold has been following this with great interest. And as soon as he hears the news that Stanley has got to the West Coast, he sends him a telegram of congratulations. And then Leopold says to his ambassador in London, this is the man. This is the man I need to get me this colony in the heart of Africa. However, Leopold says, we have to be careful. And I quote,
博马贸易站，该贸易站位于海岸附近的刚果河右岸。这是一个非凡的、了不起的成就。汤姆，他在三年里步行走了7000英里。现在，利奥波德一直在密切关注这件事。一听到斯坦利到达西海岸的消息，他立刻发去了一封贺电。接着，利奥波德对他的伦敦大使说，就是这个人。这就是我需要的这个人，他能为我赢得这个位于非洲腹地的殖民地。然而，利奥波德说，我们必须小心谨慎。我引用一下：
if I quite openly charged Stanley with the task of taking possession in my name of some part of Africa, the English will stop me. I don't want to risk losing a fine chance to secure for ourselves a slice of this magnificent African cake. So I will just give Stanley some job of exploration which would offend no one and will give us the bases and headquarters which we can take over later on. Oh the fox. The fox. So Leopold's intermediaries and emissaries keep offering Stanley, they write to Stanley and they say you know the International African Association, this fake charity would love to offer you a job.
“如果我公开指派斯坦利任务，以我的名义占领非洲的一部分，英国人会阻止我。我不想冒失去为我们自己争取这块宏伟的非洲蛋糕的一大好机会的风险。所以，我会给斯坦利一些不会冒犯任何人、又能为我们提供基地和总部以便日后接管的考察工作。”噢，这只老狐狸。老狐狸。于是，利奥波德的中间人和密使不断向斯坦利抛出橄榄枝，他们写信给斯坦利说，你知道国际非洲协会这个假慈善机构非常乐意为你提供一份工作。
Now, Stanley turns it down at first because he wants to go back to England and to see what he could get there. But when he gets back to London, although of course he's a big celebrity, the establishment are very suspicious of him, the Royal family, the foreign office and so on, because they have heard reports that Stanley has treated people extremely brutally. And I think reports that are completely justified. About half of Stanley's porters, African porters, had died on his trip of starvation or disease,
起初，斯坦利拒绝了，因为他想回英国看看能在那里捞到什么。但当他回到伦敦时，尽管他当然是个大名人，但当权派却对他非常怀疑，王室、外交部等等，因为他们听到了关于斯坦利极其残酷对待人们的报道。我认为这些报道完全是事实。斯坦利大约有一半的背夫，即非洲背夫，在旅行中死于饥饿或疾病，
and he had flogged them mercilessly and basically had driven them into the ground. And this makes people very anxious. So Richard Burton, another great explorer and not a man who, I mean, himself is prone to doing behaving quite extremely, but he said of Stanley that he shoots Africans as if they were monkeys. Yeah. In a tone of great disapproval. Yes. I mean, to keep using the word darkness, that is a shadow of darkness over Stanley's reputation.
他残酷地鞭打他们，基本上把他们折磨得精疲力竭。这让人们非常焦虑。因此，理查德·伯顿这位另一位伟大的探险家——他本人其实也并非不会做出相当极端的行为——却这样评价斯坦利：“他枪杀非洲人就像杀猴子一样。”是的。语气中充满了强烈的反对。是的。我的意思是，继续使用“黑暗”这个词，那是笼罩在斯坦利声誉上的一道黑暗阴影。
Absolutely it is. He's also, he's very awkward in his relationship with the other sex, isn't he? The fairer sex. He is indeed. I lose track of the women he's basically left and he's kind of dreaming vaguely that he'll come back and marry them. And there's a sense that he's going off into the jungle for three years so he doesn't have to deal with women. Exactly. Because they keep, they will often marry somebody else while he's gone and you can sense he comes back and he pretends to be disappointed, but actually he's already quite relieved. Anyway, and there's also a class issue.
确实如此。而且，他在与异性的关系上也显得非常笨拙，不是吗？也就是所谓的弱势性别。确实如此。我已经记不清他基本上抛弃了多少女性，他总是隐隐梦想着自己会回来娶她们。有一种感觉，他之所以去丛林里待三年，就是为了不用去应付女人。没错。因为当他离开时，她们往往会嫁给别人，你能感觉到他回来时假装很失望，但实际上他已经松了一口气。总之，这里面还有一个阶层问题。
He says, they despise me because I'm Welsh. The English are not giving me any credence at all. They don't listen to a word I say. They make up these lies about me and all this kind of thing. So in the summer of 1878, Stanley is very disappointed by his reaction and he gets an invitation from Leopold to visit him in Brussels and he says to himself, why not? Okay, I'll go and see him. And so on the 10th of June, 1878, Stanley walks into Leopold's office in the Royal Palace
他说：“他们鄙视我，因为我是威尔士人。英国人根本不信任我。他们不听我说的一个字。他们编造关于我的谎言，诸如此类。”因此，在1878年夏天，斯坦利对自己的遭遇非常失望，这时他收到了利奥波德的邀请，请他去布鲁塞尔拜访。他对自己说，为什么不呢？好吧，我去见见他。于是，在1878年6月10日，斯坦利走进了利奥波德位于布鲁塞尔皇家宫殿的办公室，
in Brussels for the meeting that will seal the fate of the Congo. And blight the lives of millions. We will be back after the break. Going up that river was like traveling back to the earliest beginnings of the world, when vegetation rioted on the earth and the big trees were kings. An empty stream, a great silence, an impenetrable forest. The air was warm, thick, heavy, sluggish. There was no joy in the brilliance of sunshine. The long stretches of the waterway ran on, deserted, into the gloom of overshadowed distances. On silvery sandbanks, hippos and alligators sunned themselves side by side.
参加了那场将决定刚果命运并毁掉数百万人生计的会议。我们休息一下，稍后回来。沿着那条河逆流而上，就像是回到了世界的最初起源，那时大地上植物疯狂生长，大树宛如君王。一条空旷的河流，一片巨大的寂静，一片不可渗透的森林。空气温暖、浓烈、沉闷、迟钝。灿烂的阳光下没有一丝欢乐。长长的河道荒凉地延伸着，通向被阴影笼罩的远方的昏暗之中。在银白色的沙洲上，河马和短吻鳄并肩享受着阳光。
The broadening waters flowed through a mob of wooded islands. You lost your way on that river as you would in a desert and butted all day long against shoals, trying to find the channel till you thought yourself bewitched and cut off forever from everything you had known once somewhere far away in another existence. So that's from Heart of Darkness. It's Joseph Conrad's hero Marlow driving a steamboat up the river Congo.
宽阔的水流穿过一群树木丛生的岛屿。你在那条河上会像在沙漠里一样迷失方向，整天撞击着浅滩，试图寻找航道，直到你觉得自己被施了魔法，永远切断了你曾经在遥远的另一个存在中知道的一切。这段话出自《黑暗的心》。它是约瑟夫·康拉德笔下的小说主人公马洛驾驶汽船沿刚果河逆流而上的情景。
And Dominic, the thing that always strikes me about that passage is it kind of has echoes of Conan Doyle's book The Lost World, the sense that going into the jungle is somehow to go back into the prehistoric past. And in fact, in the decades that follow, there will be stories told of a great long neck dinosaur that lurks in the depths of the Congo. And there's a sense that Conrad is kind of, I mean, he's articulating that in a very powerful and not uncontroversial way. Yeah, it's a very controversial passage. That's a very evocative passage that they go, the deeper and deeper they go into Africa, the further and further they're going back in time. And for Conrad's critics, sort of post-colonial critics, they say that is so loaded and so dodgy
多米尼克，这段话最让我触动的是，它某种程度上带有柯南·道尔的书《失落的世界》的迴响，那种走进丛林就仿佛回到了史前过去的感觉。事实上，在随后的几十年里，一直有传说称刚果深处潜伏着一只长颈大恐龙。而且康拉德确实在以一种非常有力且并非毫无争议的方式表达这种感觉。是的，这是一段极具争议的文字。这段文字非常引人入胜，他们越是深入非洲腹地，就越是向过去倒退。对于康拉德的批评者，也就是后殖民批评者来说，他们认为这种说法太带有偏见且十分可疑，
to be basically saying that by, to visit Africa, the deeper you go, the further backwards you travel to this kind of primeval world. But we'll unpack all that next week, Tom. But first of all, the Congo. So when Leopold and Stanley sit down that day in June 1878, which we ended the first half with, what do they actually know about this world that Conrad himself visited? This landscape, the jungle, the river and whatnot. Europeans have known about the existence
即通过访问非洲，你走得越深，你退回这种原始世界的旅程就越远。但我们下周会详细剖析这一切，汤姆。首先，我们来谈谈刚果。那么，当利奥波德和斯坦利在1878年6月的那个日子坐在一起时——也就是我们上半场结束时的情景——他们对康拉德本人曾访问过的这个世界究竟了解多少？这片风景、丛林、河流等等。欧洲人对
of the River Congo for 400 years. So the first to lay eyes on it was a Portuguese captain called Diogo Cao in 1482. And he had been sailing south along the coast of Africa like so many Portuguese sailors did there. You remember Tom, their caravels with their triangular sails. That's right. And they're putting up little kind of stone markers on there. They're putting up stone markers. So he put one on the far bank of the Congo in what's now Angola,
刚果河存在的了解已经有400年了。因此，第一个看到它的是1482年的一位名叫迪奥戈·康的葡萄牙船长。他当时正沿着非洲海岸向南航行，就像许多葡萄牙水手那样。汤姆，你还记得他们那带有三角帆的卡拉维尔帆船吗？是的。他们在那里竖起了一根根小型石标。他们在竖立石标。于是他在刚果对岸（现在的安哥拉境内）竖立了一根，
that King Zhao II of Portugal did order this land to be discovered and this pillar of stone to be erected by Diogo Cao, a squire of his household. But of course, they weren't really discovering, I mean, they were discovering from their own perspective, but they weren't the first to discover it because of course, there were a lot of people there already. So when the Portuguese arrived at the end of the 15th century, there were probably about three million people who were subjects of the kingdom of the Congo with a capital K and that was ruled by a monarch called the Manikongo and his capital was probably just over the border in what's now Angola.
葡萄牙国王若昂二世确实下令探索这片土地，并由他的家臣迪奥戈·康竖起这根石柱。但当然，他们并不是真的在发现——我的意思是，他们是从他们自己的角度在发现，但他们并不是第一个发现的人，因为在那之前，那里已经有很多人了。因此，当葡萄牙人在15世纪末抵达时，大约有300万人口是刚果王国（首字母大写）的臣民，这个王国由一位被称为“马尼刚果”的君主统治，他的首都可能就在如今安哥拉边境的另一侧。
And the people of the Congo, they were farmers. They raised pigs and yams and stuff. They didn't have wheels. They didn't have writing, but they did have a kind of state system. They had judges, they had a calendar, they had a tax system, they used shells as currency, and they already had slavery,
刚果人是农民。他们养猪、种山芋之类的作物。他们没有轮子。他们没有文字，但他们确实有一种国家体制。他们有法官，有日历，有税收制度，用贝壳作为货币，并且他们已经有了奴隶制，
which was to prove a disaster for the Congo because the Portuguese were delighted to find people, to find chiefs who were happy to sell them human beings that the Portuguese could put to work, particularly in Brazil. So Congo becomes a huge supplier of slaves to the Portuguese. By the 17th century, the Portuguese are probably shipping 15,000 slaves a year in horrific conditions. Initially to Brazil, later on they start selling them to North America as well. So in the American South, about one in four of the slaves in the 19th century had roots in equatorial Africa, which includes the kingdom of the Congo. What the Congolese made of this is very, very hard for us to tell because until the
事实证明，这对刚果来说是一场灾难，因为葡萄牙人很高兴能找到人，找到那些乐意向他们出售人类的部族首领，以便葡萄牙人可以强迫他们劳动，尤其是在巴西。因此，刚果成为葡萄牙人的巨大奴隶供应地。到了17世纪，葡萄牙人可能以可怕的条件每年运送1万5千名奴隶。最初运往巴西，后来他们也开始将其卖给北美。因此，在19世纪的美国南方，大约四分之一的奴隶都有赤道非洲的根源，其中包括刚果王国。刚果人对此作何感想，我们很难断定，因为直到
modern era, the Congolese had no written language, which is why this episode so far has been from a European perspective. Even in King Leopold's time, in the time of the Congo Free State, there is not a single memoir written by a Congolese African. So that's a problem for us as historians because it means that African voices are silent compared with European ones. Wasn't there a king? There was a king. A Christian king in the 16th century who writes to the Pope and he wrote to the Portuguese king and he complains about the slavery. He did indeed. The kind of looting of his people. So I would guess from that, that probably they're not thrilled about it.
现代以前，刚果人没有书面语言，这就是为什么到目前为止这一集都是从欧洲人的视角出发的。甚至在利奥波德国王时代，在刚果自由国时期，也没有一个刚果非洲人留下回忆录。所以这对我们历史学家来说是个问题，因为这意味着与欧洲人的声音相比，非洲人的声音是沉默的。难道没有国王吗？有一个国王。16世纪时有一位基督教国王，他写信给教皇，也写信给葡萄牙国王，抱怨奴隶制。他的确写了。抱怨对他人民的掠夺。所以我据此推测，他们对这件事大概不会感到高兴。
No, he wrote to the Portuguese king and he said, there's no, you know, you're taking too many slaves, there's nobody left. And the Portuguese king actually wrote back to him, sent him a letter and said, I've heard there's loads of people in the Congo. What are you complaining about? Shut up. And that was the extent of this meeting of minds between these two Kings. Right.
不，他写信给葡萄牙国王说：“没有，你知道的，你们抓了太多奴隶，一个人都不剩了。”而葡萄牙国王居然回信给他，信中说：“我听说刚果有的是人。你在抱怨什么？闭嘴吧。”这就是这两位国王之间思想交流的全部程度。没错。
In the years that followed, the Congo became prey to all kinds of inroads in the Portuguese, the Spanish, the Dutch. There's lots of factualism, the civil wars, and basically the kingdom falls apart. But much of this is a mystery to Europeans. Europeans can't get into the interior. They know that the Congo River is a vast river. It's the second largest river in Africa, third largest by volume in the world, but they can't go up it because once you start to go upstream, once you go up river,
在随后的几年里，刚果成为葡萄牙人、西班牙人、荷兰人各种侵扰的牺牲品。这里派系林立，内战不断，基本上整个王国四分五裂。但对欧洲人来说，这一切大部分都是个谜。欧洲人进不去内陆。他们知道刚果河是一条巨大的河流。它是非洲第二大河，按水量计算是世界第三大河，但他们无法逆流而上，因为一旦你开始逆流而上，溯河而上，
very quickly, the river gives way to 200 miles worth of rapids and gorges and canyons and so on. So you have to get out of your ship and walk. And at that point, it's very rocky terrain, what's called the Crystal Mountains. And Europeans, as soon as they started to do that, they would get malaria or yellow fever and they'd basically all die. Dominic, there is a British expedition in 1816.
很快，河流就会变成200英里长的急流、峡谷和深渊等等。所以你必须下船步行。而那时的地形非常崎岖，被称为水晶山脉。欧洲人只要一开始这样做，就会感染疟疾或黄热病，基本上全都会死掉。多米尼克，1816年曾有过一次英国探险队。
There is indeed. Led by a Royal Navy captain who describes the scenery as beautiful and not inferior to any on the banks of the Thames. Yeah. Which is of the Thames. Which is obviously the highest praise that an Englishman can possibly give. But he's a good example. He only gets a little bit of the way and then they basically have to go back because they were all horribly ill. So even in the 1870s, the vast basin of the Congo, we're talking about one and a half million square miles of territory.
确实有过。由一位英国皇家海军船长率领，他将那里的风景描述为美丽迷人，不亚于泰晤士河岸边的任何景色。是的。泰晤士河岸边。这显然是一个英国人能给出的最高赞美了。但他就是一个很好的例子。他只走了很短的一段路，然后他们基本上就不得不折返，因为所有人都病得很重。所以即使在19世纪70年代，刚果广阔的流域——我们说的是一百五十万平方英里的领土——
So that's about what, the size of India? So far space in the Congo, we're talking about one and a half million square miles of territory. So that's about what, the size of India? Yeah, I mean it's a massive, massive stretch of land and home to, now this is very controversial, but let us say somewhere between roughly eight and 12 million people. It is almost completely unknown to Europeans. They still talk about the blank space on the map, an empty space on the map, which is of course quite wrong. Now Stanley has been through it, but not all of it. Stanley had tracked the river for about 1,500 miles. So that's
那大概有多大，差不多是印度的面积吗？所以刚果的广阔流域，我们说的是一百五十万平方英里的领土。那大概有多大，差不多是印度的面积吗？是的，我的意思是这是一片巨大无比的土地，居住着——现在这很有争议——但我们假设大约有八百万到一千二百万人。它对欧洲人来说几乎完全是未知的。他们仍然在谈论地图上的空白处，地图上的空白空间，这当然是大错特错。现在斯坦利已经穿过了它，但不是全部。斯坦利沿着这条河追踪了大约1500英里。所以这
only about half the length of the Congo River. And he's only had limited interactions with the locals, but he does know two crucial things, which he's able to tell Leopold that day in the palace. First of all, the people of the Congo, they don't have anything like the military technology to resist a European takeover. It's a myth that they're completely unsophisticated. They have brilliant pottery, they're brilliant woodworkers and so on. But in terms of weapons, they only have spears and arrows and some very ancient Portuguese muskets.
只是刚果河长度的一半左右。而且他与当地人的交往有限，但他确实知道两件至关重要的事情，他那天在宫殿里把这些告诉了利奥波德。首先，刚果人民根本没有能够抵抗欧洲人接管的军事技术。认为他们完全不开化的看法是一个神话。他们拥有精美的陶器，是出色的木工等等。但在武器方面，他们只有长矛、弓箭和一些非常古老的葡萄牙滑膛枪。
So an invading European force would be able to wipe the floor with them. And the second thing, even more important, there is no one powerful state in the Congo Basin. There are more than 200 different ethnic groups. They speak 400 different languages and dialects. There's a massive variety. So some of them are Higmias who live a massive variety. So some of them are Igneous who live in the forests, and some of them are more settled farming peoples who live on the savannas.
因此，一支入侵的欧洲军队将能够轻而易举地消灭他们。第二点，甚至更重要的是，刚果盆地没有一个强大的国家。这里有200多个不同的族群。他们说400种不同的语言和方言。这里有着巨大的多样性。其中一些是住在森林里的俾格米人，还有一些是住在稀树草原上的定居农耕民族。
But they're very fragmented. And they're always fighting each other. It's a little bit like, you know, when Cortez arrived in Miso, America, and found there were all kinds of rivalries and things that he could exploit. But there isn't an equivalent of the Aztecs. There's no equivalent to the Aztecs. There's no equivalent of that. So it's even better than that.
但他们非常分散。而且他们一直在互相打仗。这有点像，你知道的，当科尔特斯抵达中美洲时，发现那里有各种各样的竞争关系，他可以加以利用。但这里没有阿兹特克的同类。这里没有阿兹特克的同类。没有那种同类的政权。所以情况甚至比那还要好。
For a European predator, the people of the Congo are the perfect prey. And Dominic, isn't there one other factor that Stanley has discovered by going along the river, which is that if you can get past the rapids up kind of into the highlands, then the Congo is very, very navigable. And there are all these kind of tributaries. So there are thousands and thousands of miles of navigable water. So it's kind of like, railways have been laid or something. If you can just get your steamboat up past these rapids, then you can use the river to go very, very deep into the Congo. And if there is raw material, say ivory, or perhaps in due course rubber, then you can use it
对一个欧洲掠夺者来说，刚果人民是完美的猎物。多米尼克，斯坦利沿河而上还发现了另一个因素，不是吗？那就是如果你能穿过急流到达高地，那么刚果河就非常非常适合通航。而且这里有各种各样的支流。因此，这里有成千上万英里的通航水域。所以这有点像，铁路已经铺好了一样。如果你能把你的汽船开过这些急流，那么你就可以利用这条河深入刚果腹地。如果那里有原材料，比如象牙，或者日后可能出现的橡胶，那么你就可以用它
to bring it back. Exactly. In other words, there are the lineaments of your transport infrastructure right there waiting for you. So for Leopold, all of this is absolutely great news. He seems to have hit it off with Stanley straight away. Leopold spoke perfect English, despite his enormous nose and his gangling awkwardness. He can be charming when he wants to and he flatters Stanley. Stanley has got a desperate for flattery because he hasn't had it in London. And that autumn, 1878, Leopold says, I'd like to offer you a five-year contract. For every year you spend in Africa, I will pay you 50,000 francs and I will pay for an expeditionary force to go with you up the Congo. So in terms of Stanley's
把它运回来。完全正确。换句话说，你的交通基础设施的路线就在那里等着你。所以对利奥波德来说，这一切绝对是个好消息。他似乎马上就和斯坦利合得来了。尽管利奥波德有着巨大的鼻子和笨拙的身材，但他英语说得很流利。他想讨人喜欢时可以非常迷人，并且他奉承斯坦利。斯坦利极度渴望得到奉承，因为他在伦敦没有得到过。1878年那个秋天，利奥波德说，我想为你提供一份五年的合同。你在非洲呆的每一年，我付给你5万法郎，我还会资助一支远征军陪你一起逆刚果河而上。所以就斯坦利的
earnings, in today's money, Leopold is effectively offering him £2 million, a lot of money for a journalist. And so he's buying Stanley's knowledge, presumably. Yes. But is he also buying Stanley's prestige as the man who knows the Congo? The sense that if he's got Stanley with him, then the project must be a realistic one. It must be a serious one. I think he's buying three things actually. So I think he's buying Stanley's knowledge.
收入而言，按今天的货币计算，利奥波德实际上是在向他提供200万英镑，对一个记者来说这是一大笔钱。所以他买的是斯坦利的知识，大概吧。是的。但他也买下了斯坦利作为“了解刚果的人”的名望吗？那种只要有斯坦利同行，这个项目就一定是现实的、严肃的感觉。我想他实际上买三样东西。首先，我认为他买的是斯坦利的知识。
Stanley knows he's gone along the river. Number two, I do think he, you're absolutely right, he's buying the prestige and the celebrities. Stanley will become the face of this charitable expedition. Right. But the third thing is he's genuinely buying Stanley's, you know, Stanley is going to have to do the work. He's going to have to put the work in on the ground. Now Leopold knows that Stanley is a hard worker and he drives other people very hard. He says to Stanley, what I want you to do.
斯坦利知道，他曾沿着这条河走过。第二，我认为你完全说得对，他买的是名望和名人效应。斯坦利将成为这次慈善探险的面孔。没错。但第三件事是，他真正买的是斯坦利的……你知道的，斯坦利必须去干活。他必须实地付出努力。现在利奥波德知道斯坦利是个工作狂，而且他对别人要求也很严。他对斯坦利说，我想要你做的是。
I want you to establish a station at the mouth of the Congo that will be our big base. Then, and this will be a really important thing, build a road or indeed a railway around these rapids, through these mountains. And basically what I want you to do, start with a road and get porters to carry disassembled steamboats through this territory to the other side of the rapids 200 miles, then reassemble the steamboats and then head upriver on the steamboats for a thousand miles establishing trading posts and stations and whatnot as you go. So this is a pretty big operation. Stanley says, fine. Now the fine point of this contract is deliberately ambiguous.
我希望你在刚果河口建立一个据点，这将是我们的主要基地。然后，这将是一件非常重要的事，围绕这些急流、穿过这些山脉修建一条公路或一条铁路。基本上我希望你做的是，从修建公路开始，让背夫们把拆解开的汽船穿过这片领土运到急流另一侧的200英里外，然后重新组装汽船，接着乘汽船逆流而上一千英里，一路建立贸易站和据点之类的地方。所以这是一个相当大的行动。斯坦利说，好的。现在，这份合同的细则被故意写得模棱两可。
The contract leaves it very unclear who Stanley is working for. Is he working for Leopold himself? Is he working for the International African Association? Or is he working for yet another organization called the Committee for Studies of the Upper Congo, which is another of Leopold's front organizations that he has set up. And Stanley must have known that something was a bit off about this because he demands, he says, I must have all the money upfront. And this plan to use porters to carry bits of steamship up to the Congo. Yeah. I mean, presumably that will require a fair degree of force.
合同很不清楚斯坦利到底是在为谁工作。他是在为利奥波德本人工作吗？他是在为国际非洲协会工作吗？还是他在为另一个名为“上刚果研究委员会”的组织工作？这是利奥波德建立的又一个傀儡组织。斯坦利肯定知道这里面有点不对劲，因为他要求——他说，我必须预支所有的资金。而这个使用背夫把轮船零件运到刚果的计划。是的。我的意思是，这大概需要相当程度的武力吧。
Yes. So is Stanley knowingly buying into that? Oh, yeah. I mean, presumably that will require a fair degree of force. Yes. So is Stanley knowingly buying into that? Oh yeah. I mean, is... Because Stanley had employed porters on his previous journeys, and that had often involved a degree of payment, but also a degree of force as well. But to carry a steamship is a different business from carrying, you know... It is. ...supplies or whatever. I mean, that's a pretty military operation.
是的。那么斯坦利是明知这一点而接受的吗？哦，是的。我的意思是，这大概需要相当程度的武力。是的。那么斯坦利是明知这一点而接受的吗？哦，是的。我的意思是……因为斯坦利在之前的旅程中也雇佣过背夫，那通常既需要支付一定报酬，但也需要一定程度的武力。但运送一艘轮船和运送，你知道的……是这样的。……物资什么的，是完全不同的事情。我的意思是，那是一项相当具有军事性质的行动。
It is. But remember, Leopold has promised he will pay for an expeditionary force, basically a mercenary force, to go upriver with Stanley. But just to be clear, Stanley is walking into this with his eyes wide open. Oh, his eyes are definitely open. And his subordinates, they have to sign the equivalent to non-disclosure agreements. They have to sign strict confidentiality clauses. They can't tell anybody about what they're doing. Again, a pretty dodgy sign I would say. Now Leopold of course, he wants to hide this from foreign competitors. He's paranoid that the Germans or the French will get in on the act, but he also wants to hide this from his own people. Because remember,
确实如此。但记住，利奥波德已经承诺他会支付一支远征军的费用，基本上是一支雇佣军，陪同斯坦利逆流而上。但要明确的是，斯坦利是睁大眼睛走入这一切的。哦，他的眼睛绝对是睁开的。而且他的下属必须签署相当于保密协议的文件。他们必须签署严格的保密条款。他们不能对任何人透露他们在做什么。再说一次，我认为这是一个相当可疑的迹象。现在利奥波德当然想对外国竞争对手隐瞒这一点。他偏执地认为德国人或法国人会插手，但他也想对本国人民隐瞒这一点。因为记住，
here's the really remarkable thing. Unlike some of the rest of the scramble of Africa, this is not being done for Belgium. It's not been done for the people or the government of Belgium. It's being done for one man, King Leopold, and that's what makes it different. So February 1879, Stanis sets off and as part of the confidentiality, he travels under an alias. He calls himself Monsieur Henri. So Monsieur Henri goes off to Africa. Meanwhile, back in Belgium, Leopold has set up yet another organisation, another front group called the International Association of the Congo. Now this, people may have lost track at this point of all the different associations. That's the point. That's what Leopold wants
这里最引人注目的是：与瓜分非洲的其他部分不同，这不是为了比利时而做的。这不是为了比利时的民众或政府而做的。这是为了一个人——利奥波德国王而做的，这正是它的不同之处。因此，在1879年2月，斯坦利出发了，作为保密措施的一部分，他使用了一个化名旅行。他自称亨利先生。于是亨利先生前往非洲。与此同时，在比利时的利奥波德又成立了另一个组织，另一个名为“刚果国际协会”的傀儡组织。现在，人们可能在这一点上已经记不清所有这些不同的协会了。这就是重点。这正是利奥波德希望
you to do. Because the names are all vaguely similar. They're very similar. He wants you to think that this is the International African Association set up at his conference. And that's a charitable one. A charitable one because it has the same flag, the same iconography, the flag is blue with the gold star. But this one is answerable just to him, the International Association of the Congo.
你做的。因为这些名字都模棱两可地相似。它们非常相似。他希望你认为这就是在他的会议上成立的国际非洲协会。那是一个慈善机构。一个慈善机构，因为它有着相同的旗标，相同的图标，旗帜是蓝底金星。但这个组织只对他一个人负责，即刚果国际协会。
And this is the organization that he intends will run his new fiefdom. It's like if you set up a very sinister exploitative organization called Oxfam or... Yeah, yeah, exactly. Exactly. Help the children. Yeah, yeah. Secretly you're doing nothing but evil. Well, if you exactly if you actually set up two groups, one could save the children and one could help the children and save the Children pretends to be charitable. You've got lots of pop stars and help the children. It's just a money-making you're just selling merch
这就是他打算用来管理他的新封地的组织。这就像你建立了一个非常阴险的剥削组织，却把它叫做乐施会或者……是的，是的，正好。没错。帮助儿童。是的，是的。背地里你做的全都是邪恶的事。嗯，如果你真的建立了两个组织，一个可以拯救儿童，一个可以帮助儿童，而“拯救儿童”假装是慈善的。你有很多流行歌星，而“帮助儿童”只是一个赚钱的机构，你只是在卖周边产品，
You're using them to dig out gold right exactly exactly. That's exactly what it is Now Leopold whilst Dan is gone Leopold gets his sort of tame client journalists to start placing articles about this in the world's press And this is brilliant. I mean I have to say it really is brilliant because in each country his sort of tame client journalists to start placing articles about this in the world's press. And this is brilliant. I mean, I have to say it really is brilliant because in each country, they sell a different message based on that country. So in Britain, in the Times, they place articles to say that what Leopold is doing is he's setting up a kind of, and I quote, a sort of society of the Red Cross. And that established kind of hospices along the banks of the Congo to help travellers and to fight slavery. And of course, people in Britain
你利用他们去挖金子，对，没错，没错。这正是它的本质。现在，乘斯坦利不在，利奥波德让他的驯服喉舌记者开始在世界各大报刊上发表关于这方面的文章。这太妙了。我的意思是，我必须说这真的很妙，因为在每个国家，他的驯服喉舌记者都会根据那个国家的情况兜售不同的信息。所以在英国，《泰晤士报》上发表文章称，利奥波德正在做的事情是建立一种——我引述一下——“类似于红十字会的社会”，并且在刚果河岸边建立了一系列收容所，以帮助旅行者并打击奴隶制。当然，英国的
will be like, they're Victorians will be all over this. In the German papers, Leopold's agents say it's going to be a Hanseatic League of the Congo, a succession of Congolese free cities based on, and I quote, Bremen, Lubeck and Hamburg. So lots of Marzipan shops running the line of the Congo. That lovely kind of stepped gable architecture. And then in American papers, Stanley has been sent to establish, and I quote, a confederation of free Negro republics.
维多利亚时代的人会对这一套深信不疑。在德国报纸上，利奥波德的代理人说这将是一个“刚果汉萨同盟”，是一系列建立在——我引述一下——“不来梅、吕贝克和汉堡”基础上的刚果自由城市。因此会有很多杏仁糖商店沿着刚果河开设。那种可爱的阶梯式山墙建筑。然后在美国报纸上，报道称斯坦利被派去建立——我引述一下——“一个自由黑人共和国联邦”。
So basically like Liberia that will become part of a United States of the Congo that will be supervised by the benevolent King Leopold. Whenever anybody reads this, they say, God, what's not to like? This sounds great. So kind. Meanwhile, Stanley is hard at work and he's again, as whatever you might think of him, he's good at doing it. In two years, he's good at doing it.
所以基本上就像利比里亚那样，将成为由慈悲的利奥波德国王监督的刚果合众国的一部分。任何人读到这些都会说，天哪，这有什么不好的？听起来太棒了。多么仁慈。与此同时，斯坦利正在努力工作，不管你对他的看法如何，他确实很擅长干这个。在两年时间里，他干得很出色。
In two years, he gets these colossal teams of workmen to carve this trail around the rapids and then to move 50 tons worth of equipment up the trail. And once they've got past the rapids, they establish a post at a place that they call Leopoldville. And this is the birthplace of modern day Kinshasa, which is now the capital of the Democratic Republic, the largest city in Africa. Is it? The largest city in Africa?
在两年里，他让这些庞大的工人群体开辟了这条绕过急流的小径，然后将50吨重的设备沿着小径运了上去。一旦他们穿过急流，他们就在一个被称为利奥波德维尔的地方建立了一个据点。这就是现代金沙萨的发源地，金沙萨现在是刚果民主共和国的首都，也是非洲最大的城市。是吗？非洲最大的城市？
It is indeed. I did not know that. And this is where they will reassemble the steamboats and then head upriver. But at this stage, I mean, we're literally talking about like a fortified blockhouse. I mean, that's all it is. Fine. Yes. So this is an extraordinary achievement, but in the sign of things to come, it comes at
确实如此。我以前不知道这一点。这就是他们重新组装汽船然后逆流而上地方。但在现阶段，我的意思是，我们字面意义上谈论的就像是一个防御性的圆木小屋。我的意思是，那就只是那样。好的。是的，这是一个非凡的成就，但作为未来事态的征兆，它付出了
a horrendous, horrendous human cost. So Stanley's subordinates, his workers, whether white or black, they die of disease, of exhaustion, of overwork. One of them is eaten by a crocodile. Because Dominic, just to say that it's not just humans who are prone to the diseases, but pack animals as well. Yes. So you can't use oxen or donkeys or whatever to transport stuff. It has to be human. You have to use human beings.
极其惨烈的人力代价。因此，斯坦利的下属、他的工人们，无论是白人还是黑人，都死于疾病、精疲力竭和过度劳累。其中一人被鳄鱼吃掉了。因为多米尼克，顺便说一句，不仅人类容易感染疾病，驮兽也是如此。是的。所以你不能用公牛、驴子或类似动物来运输物资。必须依靠人力。你必须使用人类。
And we know that he treated Europeans badly too. So we have a letter from a steamboat engineer who was called Paul Neve, who fell ill, probably with malaria or yellow fever and Neve wrote home and he said, Stanley treats me with the sort of care a blacksmith applies to repair and implement that has broken down through too rough usage. Teeth clenched in anger, he smites it again and again on the anvil. And Neve died a few weeks after writing that letter because basically Stanley had driven him into the ground.
而且我们知道他对欧洲下属也很不好。因此我们有一封汽船工程师保罗·涅夫（Paul Neve）写信，他病倒了，可能得了疟疾或黄热病，涅夫写信回家说：“斯坦利对待我的那种关怀，就像铁匠对待因使用过度而损坏的工具的修理方式一样。他咬牙切齿地在砧板上一次又一次地捶打它。”涅夫在写下那封信几周后就去世了，因为基本上斯坦利把他折磨得精疲力竭。
And of course, if Stanley does that to the European subordinates, what is he like with his African porters? Now you mentioned, Tom, how does he enforce this? He has a private army, they have a thousand rifles and they have four machine guns, Maxim guns. And if any African questions his instructions or if they even collapse, Stanley claps them in irons as an example to the others. I mean, it's not really a justification, but just to a counterpoint. Stanley works himself insanely hard as well, doesn't he? He does.
当然，如果斯坦利对欧洲下属都这样，他对非洲背夫又会怎样呢？现在你提到了，汤姆，他是如何强迫他们就范的？他有一支私人军队，他们拥有一千支步枪和四挺马克沁机枪。如果有哪个非洲人对他的指示提出质疑，或者甚至只是晕倒了，斯坦利就会给他们戴上脚镣，以儆效尤。我的意思是，这算不上什么正当理由，只是作为一个对比。斯坦利对自己也疯狂地严格要求，不是吗？他确实如此。
He's kind of relentless on his own body and health. Yeah. And he nearly dies a couple of times. He has to be invalid at home to Europe. And as soon as he's got better, he comes back out. I mean, he takes the job very seriously. He pushes himself incredibly hard. But in doing so, he kills quite a lot of other people. All the time Leopold is saying to him, hurry, hurry, you know, get as much land as you can. Get as much ivory as you can, because Leopold is terrified that the French and the Germans
他对自己的身体和健康毫不留情。是的。而且他好几次差点死掉。他不得不被送回欧洲养病。可他刚一康复，就又回来了。我的意思是，他非常认真地对待这份工作。他对自己要求极其严苛。但在这个过程中，他害死了相当多的人。利奥波德一直在催促他：“快点，快点，你知道的，能占多少土地就占多少土地。能抢多少象牙就抢多少象牙，”因为利奥波德极其害怕法国人和德国人
will beat him to it. Now this question of getting the land, how is Stanley going to do that? Well, as so often in the story of European colonialism, this comes down to an issue of treaties. Leopold has enlisted the aid of the former Regis Professor of Law at Oxford University who rejoices in the name Sir Travers Twist. That's not a real name. A Dickensian name. Yeah, that's from a novel. Sir Travers Twist has provided him with a legal opinion that a private company, i.e. the International Congo Association, is within its rights to sign treaties with African chiefs just as a sovereign country can.
会抢先一步。现在关于获取土地这个问题，斯坦利将如何做到这一点？嗯，正如欧洲殖民主义故事中经常发生的那样，这归结为一个条约问题。利奥波德争取到了牛津大学前法学尤吉斯教授的协助，这位教授的名字叫特拉弗斯·特威斯特爵士（Sir Travers Twist），听起来非常动听。这不是个真名字。一个狄更斯式名字。是的，那出自小说。特拉弗斯·特威斯特爵士为他提供了一项法律意见，即一家私营公司（即国际刚果协会）有权与非洲酋长签署条约，就像一个主权国家一样。
When Leopold has got that opinion, he sends orders to Stanley. He says, right, start signing the treaties, make them as brief as possible, and in a couple of articles, these chiefs have to give us everything. So as they go outriver, Stanley will stop and he will get out and he will start talking to the local bigwigs. Of course, when he raises the issue of treaties through various interpreters, the local chiefs have no idea what he's talking about. Remember, most of them have never seen writing before. So when Stanley says, I'd like you to make your X, your cross on this document, they have no idea what they are giving away.
当利奥波德得到这个法律意见后，他向斯坦利下达了命令。他说：“好，开始签署条约，尽量简短，在几个条款中，这些酋长必须把一切都交给我们。”因此，当他们顺流而上时，斯坦利会停下来，上岸开始与当地的大人物交谈。当然，当他通过各种翻译提出条约问题时，当地的酋长们根本不知道他在说什么。记住，他们大多数人以前从未见过文字。所以当斯坦利说：“我希望你在文件上画个叉，画个X，”他们根本不知道自己正在拱手让出什么。
I mean, as you say, this is very reminiscent of episodes we've done before. Of course, 16th century Mexico or Native Americans, the Great Plains, yeah, 90th century. Absolutely. But there's a brilliant example in the book King Leopold's ghost, terrifying example. On the 1st of April, 1884, the chiefs of Ngombi and Mathela On the 1st of April 1884, the chiefs of Ngombi and Mafela signed a deal with Stanley. Leopold would give them each one piece of cloth per month. So they're very excited at getting this cloth. In return, they give him the rights to all their territories, all tax and toll rights, all game, fishing, mining and forest rights for all time. They're giving these
我的意思是，正如你所说，这非常让人想起我们以前做过的内容。当然，16世纪的墨西哥或北美大平原的原住民，是的，19世纪。绝对是。但书中有一个精彩的例子《利奥波德国王的鬼魂》，这是一个可怕的例子。1884年4月1日，恩贡比（Ngombi）和马特拉（Mathela）的酋长们——1884年4月1日，恩贡比和马费拉的酋长们与斯坦利签署了一项协议。利奥波德每月发给他们每人一块布料。所以他们对能得到这些布料感到非常兴奋。作为回报，他们将自己所有的领土、所有的税收和过路费权利、所有的猎物、渔业、采矿和森林权利永远交给了他。他们正在将这些
rights to the Congo Association. And here is the really crucial thing. The treaty that they have signed with their mark says, they will assist by labor or otherwise any works, improvements, or expeditions which the said association shall cause at any time to be carried out in any part of these territories. And this is the real kicker. And this is what actually makes it different from the treaty sign with, let's say, native Americans in the Plains Indians or whatever, because Stanley and Leopold have not just bought their land, they've bought their labor for ever, for all time, any improvement, any work that the Congo association wants to be
权利让渡给刚果协会。这里有一个非常关键的事情。他们签署并做了标记的条约规定：他们将通过劳动或其他方式协助该协会在这些领土的任何部分随时开展的任何工程、改进或远征。这就是最关键的一点。这也正是它与同平原印第安人等原住民签署的条约真正不同的地方，因为斯坦利和利奥波德不仅买下了他们的土地，他们还永远地、永远地买下了他们的劳动力，刚果协会想要开展的任何改进、任何工程，你都必须为他们完成。
carried out, you have to do for them. Yeah. And there's no mention of you know what you'll get in return here. I mean this is a really kind of this they've given away everything. So as a trade deal, not brilliant. No, it's a very poor trade deal I think it's fair to say. Stanley is great at getting these deals. By June 1884, he assigned contracts with more than 450 different chiefs. He sales home to Europe with the treaties in his pocket, giving these people's land and labour to King Leopold. So Dominic, a question, bearing in mind what we know is going to happen, did they need
是的。而且这里根本没有提到你作为回报会得到什么。我的意思是，这真的是一种——他们把一切都送出去了。所以作为一笔贸易交易，实在算不上高明。不，这是一笔非常糟糕的交易，我认为这样说很公平。斯坦利非常擅长达成这些交易。到1884年6月，他已经与450多位不同的酋长签署了合同。他带着这些装在口袋里的条约乘船回到了欧洲，将这些人民的土地和劳动力交给了利奥波德国王。所以，多米尼克，有一个问题，鉴于我们知道接下来会发生什么，他们到底需不需要
them at all? Would it have made any difference if they hadn't got these treaties? Yes, I think it would have made a difference. These treaties are not really, they're not done because Leopold cares what the Africans think. They're done to show to the rest of Europe. So these are publicized? Yes, I've done all these deals with local chiefs. I'm very friendly with the local chiefs.
这些条约？如果他们没有得到这些条约，会有什么不同吗？是的，我认为会有所不同。这些条约其实并不是因为利奥波德在乎非洲人的想法。它们是为了向欧洲其他国家展示。所以这些都被公之于众了吗？是的，我已经和当地酋长达成了所有这些协议。我和当地酋长非常友好。
This is going to be for their benefit. Everybody wins. This has been done completely legally. It is not 16th century style conquistador conquest. So a bit like the Chinese with their. Belt and road. Belt and road. Yes.
这对他们有好处。皆大欢喜。这一切都是完全合法进行的。这不是16世纪风格的征服者征服。所以这有点像中国人的“一带一路”。一带一路。是的。
I suppose so though Chinese listeners might, might, might raise an eyebrow. But, but yeah, no, I mean, it I mean, it's a deal that Leopold is selling as it's a deal that benefits Africa, it benefits me. It's great. Everybody wins. Whether everybody does win, we will see. So he's got the treatise. He's got his steamboats going up and down the river. What he needs now is somebody to recognise this as his, because What he needs now is somebody to recognize this as his, because there is a problem. While Stanley has been up the Congo, a French explorer has landed on the other side of the river, a guy called Count Pierre Savignon de Braza. De Braza has established his own trading post on the North Bank, and this becomes known
我想是的，尽管中国听众可能会，可能会，可能会挑起眉毛。但是，但是是的，不，我的意思是，这——我的意思是，这是一笔利奥波德兜售的交易，它对非洲有利，对我有益，很棒。皆大欢喜。大家是不是真的都能皆大欢喜，我们拭目以待。所以他拿到了条约。他的汽船在河上上下行驶。他现在需要的是有人承认这是他的，因为他现在需要有人承认这是属于他的，因为这里有个问题。
as Brazzaville, which today is the capital of the formerly French Republic of the Congo. So a rival Congolese territory. And there's a massive media row between Stanley and Brazza. The Portuguese hear about this and the Portuguese say, what? We were the first at the Congo. What's going on here? Get out.
当斯坦利在刚果河上游时，一名法国探险家在河的另一边登陆了，这个人叫皮埃尔·萨维尼昂·德布拉萨伯爵（Count Pierre Savignon de Braza）。德布拉萨在北岸建立了属于他自己的贸易站，后来这里被称为布拉柴维尔，如今它是前法属刚果共和国的首都。因此出现了一个竞争对手的刚果领土。斯坦利和德布拉萨之间爆发了一场巨大的媒体骂战。葡萄牙人听说了这件事，葡萄牙人说：“什么？我们才是第一个到达刚果的。这到底是怎么回事？滚出去。”
And the British say, well, if there's any dispute about this, we would really much prefer that the Portuguese have the Congo. So this is a problem for Leopold. He needs somebody to back him. And he does something here very clever. He goes outside Europe to another relatively new country like Belgium and another country that has a history of signing treaties with indigenous people, slightly one sided treaties some people might say that end up not being worth the paper they're written
英国人则表示，好吧，如果对此有什么争议，我们宁愿让葡萄牙人拥有刚果。所以这对利奥波德来说是个问题。他需要有人支持他。在这里他做了一件非常聪明的事。他走出了欧洲，来到另一个相对年轻的国家，就像比利时一样，另一个有与土著人民签署条约历史的国家，有些人可能会说，这些条约有点一边倒，最后发现根本不值得它们所写的纸张
on. But complemented by a love of liberty. Right. And this country is of course the United States of America. And he has the perfect intermediary, another Dickensian character called Henry Shelton Sanford, who had previously been the American ambassador to Brussels. And Henry Shelton Sanford, who had previously been the American ambassador to Brussels. And Henry Shelton Sanford, if you look him up, he's got a big stovepipe hat, he's got the moustache, he's got the kind of gold, Pansone glasses. And he's got the title general hasn't he? Yeah, fake. He got given because he donated artillery or something to the union during the
的价值。但辅之以对自由的热爱。没错。这个国家当然就是美利坚合众国。他找到了完美的中间人，一个名叫亨利·谢尔顿·桑福德的狄更斯式的人物，他曾任美国驻布鲁塞尔大使。而亨利·谢尔顿·桑福德，曾任美国驻布鲁塞尔大使。亨利·谢尔顿·桑福德，如果你查查他，他戴着一顶高高的圆筒帽，留着胡子，戴着那种金边的潘松眼镜。他还有个“将军”的头衔，对吧？是的，假的。那是他在美国内战期间因捐赠大炮或
Civil War and he uses it all the time, but it's completely bogus. He's a fake general. I mean, he's perfect. And he's a massive investor in Florida. Yeah. And he's lost loads of money in Florida, Florida railroads. So he needs money, which makes him the perfect pawn for Leopold. He needs a rich friend. Leopold sends him to Washington with a personal letter to the Republican president, Chester Arthur.
某种物资而被人授予的，他总是拿这个说事，但完全是伪造的。他是个假将军。我的意思是，他太完美了。而且他是佛罗里达的大投资人。没错。他在佛罗里达亏了巨资，还有佛罗里达的铁路。所以他需要钱，这使他成为利奥波德完美的棋子。他需要一个有钱的朋友。利奥波德派他带着一封写给共和党总统切斯特·亚瑟的亲笔信前往华盛顿。
Leopold says, I'm setting up this colony in the Congo. And really it's about two things. It's about fighting slavery and about free trade. And as it happens, Arthur is a Republican and that's basically what the Republican party in the 1870s and 1880s stands for. Arthur says, oh my God, this sounds absolutely brilliant. And so in April, 1884, the US State Department becomes the first issues the very first official recognition of Leopold's colony. And they don't understand what it is because at this stage, they think it's going to be like the United States only in Africa, they absolutely think it's going to be United States and what is worse in the official statement, they muddle up the International Association
利奥波德说，我正在刚果建立这个殖民地，其实主要关乎两件事。一是反对奴隶制，二是自由贸易。碰巧的是，亚瑟是共和党人，这基本上就是19世纪70年代和80年代共和党的主张。亚瑟说，哦天哪，这听起来绝对棒极了。因此，在1884年4月，美国国务院成为第一个正式承认利奥波德殖民地的机构。他们根本不明白这是什么，因为在这个阶段，他们以为这会像美国的非洲版，他们绝对认为这就是美国，更糟糕的是，在官方声明中，他们把刚果国际协会
of the Congo and the International African Association. They use both names within about three sentences. And of course, that's exactly what Leopold wanted. That was why he did it, because he does. He wants everybody to be confused. He is cunning, isn't he? He is a fox. He is a fox.
和非洲国际协会搞混了。他们在差不多三句话里同时使用了这两个名字。当然，这正是利奥波德想要的。这就是他这样做的原因，因为他就是想让所有人都糊涂。他真的很狡猾，对吧？他就像一只狐狸。他就是一只狐狸。
Now, at this point, when the Americans have recognized it, the French are the next to get on board. Why? Because even though they wanted it themselves, they become paranoid that Leopold is going to run out of money and sell it to the British. And is that because of Stanley? Exactly. The Stanley would be the intermediary. Hang out in London and everything and...
现在，当美国人承认了之后，法国人紧随其后也加入了进来。为什么？因为尽管他们自己也想要，但他们开始患得患失，担心利奥波德会花光钱然后把刚果卖给英国人。是因为斯坦利吗？没错。斯坦利会成为中间人。在伦敦闲逛以及一切……
That is the last thing they want. And also, the French don't need to feel intimidated by Belgium, do they? No, I guess not. I guess not. And they kind of are still thinking, well, need to feel intimidated by Belgium, do they? No, I guess not. I guess not. And they kind of are still thinking, well, if the Belgians get it, at least it's not the Germans. Next are the Germans. Now Bismarck, the Chancellor of Germany, the great statesman of Germany, he sees through
那是他们最不想看到的。而且，法国人没必要对比利时感到畏惧，对吧？不，我想是的。我想是的。而且他们心里还在想，好吧，如果比利时人得到了它，至少总比德国人强。接下来是德国人。现在德国首相俾斯麦，德国伟大的政治家，他把
Leopold I think a little bit because on the documents that he gets, he writes the words swindle and fantasies. And he's not wrong, is he? But Bismarck thinks, I don't want the French to get the Congo or Britain. So maybe if little Belgium gets it. Yeah, fine. It's the weakness of Belgium that Leopold is basically leveraging. Even though Belgium is not going to get it, but Leopold himself, that's the great irony of all this.
利奥波德看穿了一点，因为他在收到的文件上写下了“骗局”和“幻想”这两个词。他没说错，对吧？但俾斯麦想，我可不想让法国人或英国人得到刚果。所以如果小比利时得到了，也许也行。好吧，利奥波德利用的正是比利时的软弱。尽管比利时并不会得到它，但利奥波德本人会得到，这就是这一切莫大的讽刺。
All this comes to a head at the conference in Berlin that opens at the end of 1884. So this is the great conference that marks the sort of high point. Disraeli and... The scramble for Africa. ...Bismarck and yeah. And there are delegates from America, from Russia, from the Ottoman Empire. Of course, no Africans deciding their own destiny. And there are delegates from America, from Russia, from the Ottoman Empire. Of course, no Africans deciding their own destiny.
这一切在1884年底开幕的柏林会议上达到了顶点。所以这是一场标志着某种高潮的盛大会议。迪斯雷利和……瓜分非洲的俾斯麦等等。大会有来自美国、俄罗斯、奥斯曼帝国的代表。当然，没有一个非洲人能决定自己的命运。有来自美国、俄罗斯、奥斯曼帝国的代表。当然，没有一个非洲人能决定自己的命运。
Nobody thinks that would be remotely appropriate. Now actually, Stanley is there as an advisor to the American delegation. And it says something that Stanley himself feels a little bit queasy about this spectacle. He says that the sight of all the delegates rushing to carve up Africa reminded him of when he was on an expedition and they would kill some sort of beast. And
没有人会认为这有什么不妥。其实，斯坦利作为美国代表团的顾问也出席了会议。有一点很说明问题，那就是斯坦利本人对这种场面也感到有点反胃。他说，看到所有代表争先恐后地去瓜分非洲，让他想起了自己以前在远征时杀死某种野兽的场景，然后
he says, my porters, you know, they would rush with gleaming knives for slaughtered game. And that's what these delegates are like. Well, I suppose to hack off the ivory, to hack off the ivory. Exactly. The tusks. So by February 1885 the conference has reached an agreement and for Leopold it is the perfect result. It's a total triumph. All the powers agree that they will recognise the International Congo Association as the owner of almost all of the Congo Basin. And that's the dodgy one not the humanitarian one. Exactly the dodgy one. Leopold's private company. So he has got a territory
他说，我的挑夫们，你知道的，他们会拿着闪亮的刀子扑向被屠宰的猎物。这些代表们就像那样。好吧，我想是为了砍下象牙，砍下象牙。没错。象牙。因此，到1885年2月，会议达成了一致，对利奥波德来说，这是最完美的结果。这是一场彻底的胜利。所有列强都同意承认刚果国际协会为几乎整个刚果盆地的所有者。那是那个不正规的协会，而不是人道主义协会。没错，那个不正规的协会。利奥波德的私人公司。所以他拥有了一块
76 times the size of Belgium and it will belong not to Belgium but to Leopold personally. So at last he has the fiefdom he wanted. Three months later, in May 1885, he drops all the fiction. The International Congo Association is allowed to lapse. The only thing that remains of it is its flag, the blue flag with the gold star. And on the 29th of May, by royal decree, its lands, this huge stretch of territory, is renamed the État Indépendant du Congo, the free state of the Congo, and Leopold is named as its founding sovereign. He kind of briefly considered calling himself emperor of the Congo, didn't he?
面积达比利时76倍的领土，它不属于比利时，而是属于利奥波德个人。所以他终于得到了他梦寐以求的封地。三个月后，即1885年5月，他抛开了所有的伪装。刚果国际协会名存实亡。唯一保留下来的只有它的旗帜，那面带有金色星星的蓝旗。5月29日，通过皇家法令，这片土地、这片巨大的领地被更名为刚果自由邦（État Indépendant du Congo），利奥波德被封为创始君主。他曾经短暂地考虑过自称为刚果皇帝，对吧？
He did. And giving all the various chieftains who'd signed treaties with him outfits modelled on the uniforms of the beef eaters. Yeah, be very hot. Very sensible wearing. Inappropriate, inappropriate garb. Banks of the Congo. Very sensible wearing. Inappropriate, inappropriate garb. Banks of the Congo.
他确实想过。还想把所有跟他签过条约的部落酋长的服装都设计成皇家近卫军制服的样式。对，穿起来一定很热。非常明智的穿着。不合时宜、不合时宜的服饰。刚果河畔。非常明智的穿着。不合时宜、不合时宜的服饰。刚果河畔。
Exactly. Yeah. But now that the Congo Free State has been set up with Leopold as its monarch, for the people of the Congo, the real horror begins. The horror, the horror one might almost say. And if you are a member of the Rest is History Club, then you can hear the next two episodes right now. If not, you can sign up at therestlesshistory.com and we will be back next time continuing our journey into the heart of darkness. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
没错。是的。但现在，随着以利奥波德为君主的刚果自由邦的建立，对刚果人民来说，真正的恐怖开始了。可以说是恐怖，恐怖。如果你是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的会员，那么你现在就可以收听接下来两集的节目。如果不是，你可以在therestlesshistory.com注册，我们下期将继续带领大家深入黑暗之心。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。